The other day was chocolate.
Thank you, Koji Ayano. I
didn't call you to talk about that, but
the information provided by Kushida before Valentine's Day
was accurate. I
would like Vice President Kiriyama to post this information on the bulletin board.
If it was discovered that he was trying to save Ichinose, the student council's trust
would fall.In that case, the famous student council president would be damaged more than anyone else.I
think that would be a welcome thing, but in that case, the person who would be
condemned would be me.You are here.  If you say "Deno,"
then I
'll be reporting to the former student council president as someone who has already been taken into account. That
's fine. I'll compose a big song for you. Thank you. If it's helpful, that's the
best thing. I
understand.  Right,
just confirm that you've transferred the amount of information and you'll be fine.I'll
transfer half of the points that will continue to come to me.That's fine.As
long as I have this money, I won't be against you.As
expected of you, Kimihori.  I'm totally different from Kita-san, so I hope you'll
continue to support me.I've never taken advantage of Sakayanagi's provocations or saved Ichinose, and
I'm just a family man.The only thing I wanted to know about this series of events was the
information Kushida Nori had.  I checked the quantity and
quality and expelled them.